Netflix's deliciously dark adaptation of
the best-selling books a series of
unfortunate events is absolutely loaded
with Easter eggs and references
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to whip
through some of my favorite Easter eggs
cameos and connections to TV shows
movies and Lemony Snicket's original
books I found in the TV series ok quick
warning there are spoilers ahead so if
you want to avoid those look away look
away but don't forget to come back here
when you are ready before this show
actress Melina Wiseman who plays violet
Baudelaire was best known for her role
as the young Kara zor-el in the TV show
Supergirl and there's a great Supergirl
hat tip in part one as a reptile room
yes when violet and her siblings sit
down to eat with their Guardian
dachshund Monty Montgomery and Stefano
violet asks could you please pass the
potstickers which is a delicious
reference the super girls love of that
particular food which we've seen a
number of times in the Supergirl TV
series it's only violet could have
melted Count Olaf face when he
deliberately ate all the pot stickers
the way that Cara jokingly told her
sister she do in Supergirl and the
Baudelaire children wouldn't have had to
deal with all those unfortunate events
during the tunnel scenes in the first
episode Lemony Snicket walked past a
variety of signs many of which are
references to characters in the original
books some of whom will no doubt see in
future seasons for example was assigned
to julienne which is a shout-out to
Geraldine Julianne a reporter at The
Daily Concilio where Eleanor Poe is the
actor in chief speaking of which
although Julianne hasn't appeared in the
TV series yet Eleanor opposed does
mention head star reporter who wrote a
front page feature about the Baudelaire
mansion fire and whose fire line we can
see on another article about the
Baudelaire children another sign we see
in school Remora which is a reference to
mr. Remora a teacher at the prep school
where violet Klaus and Soni find
themselves at the end of season 1 and
that's also were in the book the austere
Academy the Baudelaires meets a very
mean school girl Carmelita spats add to
the science of editions that refers to
Captain Widow shion's The Stepfather the
hook-handed man who also gets a sign in
the tunnels featuring his named fernell
there are also signs the character to
appear in later episodes of season one
including Montgomery the children's
Guardian and whistles the surname of the
Baudelaire Guardian and Josephine
Strauss Count Olaf neighbor justice
Strauss Snicket a reference to writer
narrator a lemony or his siblings Jack
and KITT and Quagmire the surname of
cobie smulders and Will Arnett's mother
and father characters whose children end
up at the same school as the Baudelaire
over the course of season one of the
shows are a number of nods to all the
wrong questions a collection of four
books that serve as a prequel to the
series of unfortunate events novels in
Episode three Klaus asks violence how
did he find us when Count Olaf turns up
disguised as Stephano her uncle Monty's
house to which violet replies that's the
wrong question and in episode 7 after
the children discuss whether Count Olaf
will find them at the mill
narrator Lemony Snicket says violets was
asking the wrong questions also in
episode 2 and violet and Klaus are
looking for their missing sister funny
the dastardly count asks them when did
you see her last which is actually the
title of the second book in the all the
wrong question series in real life
lemony snicket is actually the pen name
for author Daniel handler and although
actor Patrick Warburton plays the part
of Snicket on-screen handler does
actually appears three times in the show
as well in Episode five went on
Josephina shopping at the market handler
pops up selling fish heads at a street
store and in episode six of the storms
coming he runs across the street yelling
save the fish heads then in Episode
seven he makes another appearance this
time interacting with mr. Poe who's
desperate to find the boteler children
who he doesn't realize have run away to
the lucky smells lumbermill mr. Poe
looks at the camera and cries it's a
catastrophe and presidented it's off
book it's unfortunate then he turns to
handle a fish head seller and says the
Baudelaires are lost that unsupervised
do you know what that means to each
handler replies without supervision
this is an ingeniously meta moment as in
the original book mr. Poe knows exactly
where the children are at this moment
because he takes them to poultryville
himself were the millers to meet their
next guardian so that part of the story
in the TV series had quite literally
gone off book impostor of the wide
window after Count Olaf forces josephine
to write
leaving the Baudelaire children in his
care she rushes into her library to try
and figure out a means of escape and
when hola Sofia disguised as Captain
sham at the time notices that Josefina
shut the library doors behind her she
hobbled up the hallway after her saying
here's Shammi which is Ana March to
Stanley Kubrick's movie The Shining and
Jack Nicholson's famous line here's
Johnny which he says if he breaks down
the door to the bathroom where his
characters wife is hiding in 2004 the
first three books in Lemony Snicket's A
Series of Unfortunate Events were
adapted into a movie starring Jim Carrey
as Count Olaf and like Netflix his
version of the bordello story that movie
featured the character of Justice
Strauss who is played by an actress
called Catherine O Hara whose names
should ring a bell if you've watched the
closing credits with series and forces
event on Netflix as this time Catherine
O'Hara
also played the scheming optometrist dr.
Georgina all well in the show which adds
another metal layer of humor to the
scene were dr. Orwell's house clouds
about an optometrist who changed her
looks to assume a new identity in a
faraway town in the season finales as a
lovely Easter Egg to the books as well
as a tease for season two when Anna
Reiter Lemony Snicket's explained
hypnosis to us saying that the
Encyclopedia hypnotic earth tells a man
who upon hearing the word Nero could
certainly play an instrument he'd never
studied then the camera cuts to a woman
playing a violin in a movie that
Snicket's watching on TV this is a nice
nod for the character of vice-principal
Nero who runs the boarding school where
we see the Baudelaire children at the
end of season one in the books
vice-principal Nero is a nasty character
and an awful violin player who forces
his students to listen to his
performances his character's name and
violent obsession were likely inspired
by the Roman Emperor Nero and towards
the end of the eighth episode we also
see the silhouette of a person playing
the violin again letting us know that
we'll be seeing vice-principal Nero in
season two of course there are tons more
Easter eggs and references in the show
but what are your favorites and what are
you looking forward to seeing in season
two and who would you like to see cast
in some of the new roles and let's begin
your ideas in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video do please like
and share it and subscribe for more of
my easter egg videos and amazing movie
and TV secrets click or tap here for
more videos you might like thanks for
watching and see you next time you'd be
going review